Well, x equals three is certainly a statement.
We've seen examples like this before.
You might have thought that a statement has to end in a semicolon,
but if we scroll back to our grammar a bit,
we see, no, a statement can be identifier equals expression,
and those semicolons come in when we have multiple statements,
like in a compound statement block.
Similarly, x equals 3 divided by 2.
Any expression can go on the right-hand side of the equal sign,
and we saw that our grammar for expression earlier included binary operators like division.
This totally works.
This series of tokens, if x is less than 5 then open curly brace x equals x plus 1 curly brace
looks very convincing.
It's almost right, but it's missing a semicolon.
Inside these compound blocks we really need those. This one doesn't work.
The one right below it has that semicolon, so it can be derived from "stmt" in our grammar.
Over here inside our compound statement we have two smaller statements--
x is x plus 1 and y is 3.
Each one of which is an individual statement,
and each one of which is terminated by a semicolon.
That's the rule we established earlier.
Finally over here we have an if-then-else statement.
This was a little tricky.
In Python conceptually this might work out, but in JavaScript we explicitly need the else token.
This one is not derivable from stmt, even though the rest of it is well-formed.